j'ai de ténacité jacqueline auriol est
décédé à l'âge de 82 ans
première femme pilote d'essai elle avait
dans les années 50 établi quatre records
du monde de vitesse sur avion à réaction
laurence de chefs nous retrace cet
itinéraire hors du commun
elle a été la première femme à franchir
le mur du son jacqueline auriol belle
fille du président vincent auriol a
marqué l'histoire de l'aviation par une
série de records de vitesse
malgré un terrible accident à bord d'un
hydravion en 1949
jacqueline devient la première femme
pilote d'essai elle s'impose dans cette
discipline jusque là réservés aux hommes
ses exploits lui valu une renommée
internationale 8 118 km heure aux
commandes d'agents pied en 1951 et dix
ans plus tard plus de 2000 km heure sur
un mirage iii des exploits qui n'ont
rien de gratuit pour prendre sur le plan
national est important pour le matériel
d'une part c'est à dire pour relever des
façons
tout à fait suffisantes les performances
d'un avion et tout peut-être aussi sur
le plan humain faut que l'on prenne s
certains hommes il est indispensable
pour que vous le plus de jeunes possible
donc envie de venir à l'aviation
entre 1950 et 1960 jacqueline auriol
rivalise avec une autre jacqueline
l'aviatrice jacqueline cochrane elle se
volent les records mais deviennent des
amis une centaine d'appareils tester 20
ans de pilotage sur les avions les plus
rapides
elle est en 1975 chargé de mission au
ministère de la coopération
jacqueline auriol fut un modèle pour
plusieurs générations de femmes
elle fut surtout l'une des héroïnes
d'une étape capitale pour l'aéronautique
le passage aux vitesses supersoniques